do you know that scientists found out  that covid can affect your brain along  with the lungs you might be thinking how  is it possible  researchers recently found that  receptors for covid entry is present in  neurons and choroid plexus chloride  plexus is a structure that secretes  cerebrospinal fluid and the covid virus  can infect both these cell types  especially the choroid plexus cells  scientists created stem cell derived  mini brains or organoids in the lab and  they found out  choroid plexus which forms the blood csf  barrier is disrupted  when covid affects our brain  and this leads to leakage of harmful  substances from the blood to the brain  subscribe for more